welcome back to las vegas now it is
military appreciation month in findlay
subaru of las vegas the sponsors of this
next segment are sharing the love to
military members and families
[Music]
i'm burton hughes general manager of
subaru of las vegas wishing you a happy
military appreciation month you know i
just want to talk about my dad for a
moment he served two tours of duty one
in the second world war and then another
in the korean conflict from the navy he
went to the marines and then my brother
served on the uss enterprise the very
first nuclear-powered
aircraft carrier and i'm so proud of my
family for their service to our country
and you know i just can't i can't say
enough about our military both those
that have served and those who are
current actively serving those who gave
their lives it's just near and dear to
our hearts at subaru of las vegas and we
want to honor each and every one subaru
of america has a great active military
program and those that have just
recently retired from the military and
they they give 500 towards the purchase
of a new or lease of a new subaru we
also back that up and we want to include
all of our veterans and those who are
currently serving and include pre-owned
certified pre-owned and and also new
cars we back it up with also a 500
discount we also have the community hero
discount so that is for our active and
former military personnel as well as
first responders and educators and that
is 15 off on the subaru products the
warranties and and things like that so
we just want everyone to know how much
we love and appreciate your service
we have a lot going on for military
appreciation month here at super of las
vegas in support of all active fallen
and retired military personnel findlay
super las vegas is filling the boots the
entire month of may with monetary
donations that will benefit the uso
nevada we've actually have real retired
military boots warned by active military
members here that we are filling with
donations on may 20th findlay super las
vegas is supporting and playing in the
first annual golfing for veterans golf
tournament hosted by the summerlin
rotary club we are so honored to be the
event sponsor because it benefits four
amazing non-profit organizations that
truly touch our military's lives lastly
on may 23rd findlay subaru of las vegas
is hosting a surprise memorial day
barbecue for the nevada state veterans
home staff and residents after two years
of not allowing visitation due to covid
we are excited to bring smiles to the
local veterans currently in nevada state
veterans home and personally thank each
resident for their service so with all
that i just want to say again thank you
for your service we love you appreciate
you and you are a part of our family so
when you come to subaru of las vegas
just come down here and know that we
love and support you every single day
thank you to findlay subaru of las vegas
for sponsoring that segment help them
celebrate military appreciation month so
for more information call 702-495-2100
and remember their special offer 1.9
financing for well-qualified buyers for
up to 48 months on select 2022 models
stacy